so did you hear about this bombshell
bombshell it's a bombshell there was
there was a huge bombshell this past
weekend new allegations against against
Brett Kavanaugh new allegations hooray
that's very exciting they got him now
new allegations that's the left was was
very excited about this
they can't even you know that's one
thing before we get into these
allegations such as they are one thing
you notice about the left is that they
can't when someone they dislike has been
accused of sexual assault or whatever
they can't contain their Glee about it
they're there they're extremely happy
they don't even pretend to really be
concerned about the alleged victim they
just they're so happy that that this
person has supposedly done this thing
well so in peach Cavanaugh was trending
Democrat presidential candidates got in
on the act calling for his impeachment
the media was having a field day was all
over the place
this new allegation of sexual assault
and that was that was all the story they
were telling anyway but of course it all
comes crashing down now we're gonna go
through this we're gonna talk about the
allegation and and everything else will
follow the trajectory of this alleged
bombshell and it began on on Saturday
with the New York Times publishing an
article by Robyn Pogrebin and Kate Kelly
who are writing a book about Brett
Kavanaugh and during their investigation
for the book they uncovered by the way
there are air quotes around a lot of the
things I'm saying here investigation air
quotes uncovered air goes air quotes
fresh allegations air quotes so just
everything I'm saying just do your own
air quotes these are fresh allegations
which actually aren't fresh at all they
go back 30 years to Cavanaugh's college
days and they are accusations that were
known to reporters who are covering the
Cavanaugh case the Cavanaugh hearings
but they weren't published before and
why weren't they published well I think
we'll see in a minute first it's kind of
weird the New York Times had this
alleged bombshell but they didn't make
that
a headline and I was confused at first
when I when I first started seeing this
people freaking out online about these
allegations and then they were linking
to this New York Times article click on
the New York Times article and the
headline has nothing to do with any new
allegations the headline is Brett
Kavanaugh it fit in with the privileged
kids she did not
Debra Ramirez is Yale experience says
much about the college's efforts to
diversify its student body in the 1980s
and so you read that you say what Debra
Ramirez diversifying the student body
what what Debra Ramirez is that woman
who claimed that that Cavanaugh shoved
his his his privates into her face at a
party at a college party and we knew
about her why is she the headline well
maybe because the bombshell allegation
isn't much of a bombshell at all but you
could judge for yourself according to a
guy named max tire who by the way is a
Clinton associate and that's quite it
that's quite a hell of a by the way it's
not even really a by the way that's it's
a very important part of this story this
is a Clinton associate he saw he says
that he saw Brett Cavanaugh's friends
force Brett Cavanaugh's penis into a
girl's hand at a college party thirty
years ago now let's let's stop there for
for just a moment even if this event
really happened which it didn't and and
we'll get to that in a second but but
even if it did I'm I'm trying to
understand the the logistics of this I
don't really want to picture it but I if
I tried to picture it what what how does
a a third party individual force someone
else's penis into someone else's hands
what what does that even look like can
you eat why I don't even I don't even
understand what the allegation is
supposed to be what are what exactly are
you claiming happened and how is
no follow-up okay if you hear if someone
says yeah I saw Brett Kavanaugh someone
forced by Kevin's penis huh how do you
not follow up and say ways like what it
described for me exactly what happened
point A to point B Point C just take me
through the how do you not do that how
do you just say oh okay moving on the
clay my guess is that Cavanaugh had his
pants down at a at a party and and and
well that's also the pants were down and
then he was somehow he was he was forced
his his his body or his his penis I
don't know but it was forced to make
contact with the girl say hey what so it
seems to me that that there are two
there are two possibilities here for
this made-up story one is that Brett
Kavanaugh had his head his pants down
and his and his you know his his
situation was was on full display and a
girl just so happened to innocently
accidentally have her hand in the
vicinity of Brett Cavanaugh's penis you
know and then he was pushed and then the
contact was made in which case it would
seem like that really wasn't much of an
accident because I I don't know I mean
what scenario would you ever
accidentally have your hand in the
vicinity of of that or we would have to
imagine that the girl was somewhere
across the room she was dragged by the
hand and then Brett Kavanaugh was
dragged by the well we won't go into
that and and and then and then contact
was made from that either way it just it
doesn't it doesn't make any sense and so
before we even get to the fact that this
didn't really happen it's like even if
it did what what okay all we can say
about that is okay that's weird that's a
weird thing okay
happened 30 years ago obviously we're
missing some pieces of this story anyway
moving on and and and besides which even
if we look over look all of that
wouldn't the culprit in this case be the
person who forced Brett Kavanaugh you
know forced this contact to take but the
accusation is that he was somehow
propelled forward against
well so isn't isn't he also a victim of
sexual assault in that case it's just a
very weird claim that makes no sense at
all something that again even if it did
happen
however it could have happened
logistically it wouldn't matter it
wouldn't make Cavanaugh a rapist or
anything close to that
so we could just say okay that happened
who cares moving on but of course it
didn't happen the New York Times two
days after publishing the original piece
issued a correction this morning and the
correction this is a this is a hell of a
correction this isn't really a
correction so much as a I mean really
this is this should be in effect what it
is is a retraction of the story but they
call it a correction and the correction
says an earlier version of this article
which was adapted from the forthcoming
book from a forthcoming book did not
include one element of the books account
regarding an assertion by a Yale
classmate that friends of Brett
Kavanaugh pushed his penis into the hand
of a female student at a drunken dorm
party it didn't include one element you
ready for the element it didn't include
the book reports that the female student
declined to be interviewed and friends
say she doesn't recall the incident that
information has been added to the
article okay so the alleged victim says
she doesn't remember anything like that
happening this is a story from a
politically partisan man about what
happened to a woman but the woman has no
recollection of it so if we're believing
women then wouldn't we have to just
discard this believe women okay well the
woman says I don't know I don't remember
all you can do then is is is there's
nothing just move on or if it did happen
or if something like it happened it was
such a non-event such a minor thing that
she retained no memory of it so believe
women has
become believed men who tell stories
about what happened to women thirty
years ago at college parties and that
just does not have the same ring to it
you know so and and I guarantee you
here's what's gonna happen next next
they're gonna start telling us that the
reason the woman doesn't remember it is
because she's so traumatized that it's a
repressed memory it was she so you know
what they'll tell us they'll tell us
that the fact she doesn't remember it is
even more proof that it did happen
because it was so traumatic for her to
make that contact with Brett
Cavanaugh's remember that she has to
repress that I get you know I'm not
joking that's what they're gonna tell us
but where are we left we are left again
with the fact that the truth doesn't
matter anymore the truth has been
slaughtered on the altar of partisanship
and from the left's point of view all
that matter matters is to destroy
Cavanaugh
and that's all that anyone cares about
and this is you know I believe this is
not just the attitude among Democrat
politicians though it is their attitude
for sure and among media elites and so
on I think this is sort of the average
leftist Democrat this is how they feel
as well I think most of the average
leftist out there they realize that a
lot they must realize that a lot of this
stuff is at least probably bogus but
they don't care because they say well we
got to take Cavan all down he's a threat
to women's rights or whatever nonsense
this latest allegation even before we
get to the correction quote-unquote
saying if the woman doesn't remember it
even before you get to that that's why
I've been harping on we don't that
almost is irrelevant because the actual
story itself is irrelevant
and so if you actually read the store
there's no way at all these people are
in peach Cavanaugh he's a rapist there
is no way there is no way that a sincere
person that a person that a an
intelligent person could sincerely read
that story and come away thinking well
that's rape
he's a rapist no one could think that
there's no way it's not possible the
even if you take it seriously the most
you could think is wow that's weird so
if you're going all the way all these
the rapists
there's no way you actually think that
they're only saying that because they
want to get rid of Cavanagh and for them
the ends justify the means and this is
this is where ends justify the means
that mentality that philosophy this is
where that really rears its ugly head is
is is I think there are a lot of people
in this country that that's the way they
look at it that truth doesn't matter
honesty really doesn't matter all that
matters is we have this end in mind we
have this goal in mind and we're gonna
do whatever needs to be done to get
there and it just it doesn't forgot to
destroy an innocent man we're gonna do
it if we have to if we have to smear
someone if we have to amplify and
elevate lies and everything then we'll
do it and you know what here's what else
they think the person
Cavan all in this case even if he didn't
do these things he still deserves it
because he disagrees with us that
psychologically that's an important part
of this of the story here I think is
that the people who are amplifying and
running with these very obvious smears
and lies remember when when
what's-her-name was a crazy woman sweat
Nick when sweat Nick and and avenatti
came out with their story claiming that
that Kavanagh was part of a roving gang
of of serial rapists who were who were
terrorizing the DC area for much of the
80s just going around and and and and
you know and they would have these
essentially raped parties where women
will be raped one at a time and somehow
women would still show up to these
parties
remember when that story when that when
that claim was was made clearly
ridiculous even if you think that
Kavanagh even if you think that the Ford
allegations are true there's no way just
the sweatin ik thing would still be too
crazy to accept but remember that when
that allegation was made most leftist
including media members Democrats they
went with it they they went with that
story for as long as they possibly could
did they really believe it no but their
attitude is number one ends justify the
means number two Brett Kavanaugh
deserves it because he disagrees with us
he's a bigot but by default he's a bigot
he's a sexist he's all he's all the
worst things in the world because he
disagrees with us and so even if he
didn't really commit rape he has in
effect ideologically done that and so we
can still pin this on him and he
deserves it that's the way it is you
know what it is with the left I think
it's very similar it's it's kind of like
what happened to OJ where I think
prosecutors with the adult with the
weird thing where he stole back his own
merchandise and he got him this absurd
sentence for it the kind of thing that
most people if you did that whatever
that whatever that whole situation was
you might not even go to jail for I
think everyone understood that what
prosecutors were doing is they were they
realized that that OJ had committed
murder and gotten away with it they got
their second crack at him and even
though the second crime wasn't nearly as
serious they still said well we yeah but
we know that he committed murder so
we're just gonna that's the main thing
we're trying to punish here and so they
sent him to jail and with the left's
attitudes are kind of the same thing
where they think with Kavanagh yeah he
didn't really do this stuff but he has
committed an underlying crime only the
underlying crime in this case is not
murder it's just that he has the wrong
ideology
that's the underlying crime and so
whatever we can stick on them in order
to punish him for that we'll do it and
it's justified all right um I would be
remiss if I didn't mention this it's
it's huge news Sam Smith
you know Sam Smith the the pop singer
the guy that sang what are you saying is
saying stay with me and and maybe some
other songs anyway Sam Smith has come
out as multiple he's come out as plural
he is to apparently or maybe three he is
he's multiple people
Sam Smith says that his pronouns now are
they then those are his pronouns or or
those are their pronouns I should say
now I have to read for you the BuzzFeed
article about this breaking news and as
I read please keep in mind that I'm not
making this up this is all real this is
a real article this is a real story
here's what BuzzFeed says singer Sam
Smith who came out as non non binary
earlier this year announced on Friday
that their gender pronouns are they
slash them after a lifetime of being at
war with my gender I've decided to
embrace myself for Who I am inside and
out they said in a Twitter thread I'm so
excited and privileged to be surrounded
by people that support me in this
decision Smith continued but I've been
very nervous about announcing this
because I care too much about what
people think but f it when they
previously came out as non-binary Smith
said they would keep he/him pronouns
their thoughts and feelings on the
matter have since involved evolved Smith
has publicly talked about their
curiosity with sexuality and gender and
has typically expressed ambiguous
feelings about the latter Smith's
decision to use they/them pronouns makes
them the latest celebrity in a long line
of mainstream actors and writers who
have done the same thing including
younger actor Nick o Tortola and Poe's
star in D amour it should be noted that
someone's name or pronoun do not
necessarily tell you any
about their gender or other identities
according to my pronouns a resource for
educating people about inclusive pronoun
language in their thread about the news
Smith acknowledged that there might be
mistakes and misgendering by people
whose intentions may not necessarily
mean to harm or hurt but all I ask you
please is to try they said Smith also
told fans that this was still this was a
very fresh change and they were not at a
place to eloquently speak at length
about what it means to be non-binary but
I can't wait for the day that I am they
added ok love you all
Smith said in their final tweet in the
thread well this is just utter I wanted
to read all that to you because this is
BuzzFeed BuzzFeed been being very well
woke of course as we know and so they're
using they okay they BuzzFeed are using
the quote quote correct pronouns for
they Sam Smith and as I read it to you
you have no idea what the hell I'm
saying because or you have no idea who
that they refers to in any given
sentence it's just total nonsense and
it'll just just take that last paragraph
for example Smith also told fans that
this was still a very fresh change and
they were not at a place to speak at
length about it well ok in in normal
English if you read that sentence Smith
all still fans that this was still a
fresh very fresh change and they were
not at a place you would think that they
refers to the fans because the fans are
the plural entity in that sentence but
in this case it refers back to Smith now
it but it doesn't make any sense this is
again just total nonsense the you know
we call this enlightened and tolerant
and and and diverse and everything but
there's another term for it bad grammar
this is just bad grammar that's all this
is this is a very bad grammar this is
bad writing so look here's the thing
first of all this is this is along with
being bad grammar this is pure unn
dull traded narcissism this is just
great a pure narcissism injected
straight into the vein this is someone's
Sam Smith or the Sam Smith's I suppose
and by the way he keeps referring to
himself as I and me shouldn't he be
saying you know I don't know how so he
should be saying we I guess
shouldn't be saying us and we if he's a
they then he can't also be an i oh but
of course doesn't matter because he gets
to make up the rules as he goes along
you just twist the English language tear
apart rules of grammar cut it all down
because that's what he wants to do
that's what they want to do and why
because the Sam Smith's consider
themselves to be so interesting so deep
so mysterious right so so profound that
normal grammar can't apply to him or
them so he identifies as they what the
hell does that mean can anyone explain
it to me okay let's just let's just talk
at a very at a very elemental elementary
level here it explained to me what if
they feels he say I identify as Ave I
feel like a day well what does that mean
what do you mean it would explain to me
the the psychological experience the
inner life of as a because I'm thinking
now what would comes to mind is a
schizophrenic you you must be but if
you're telling me you're not a
schizophrenic and and you feel as though
you are just one person and not two or
three or four then what does it mean for
a were a single individual to feel like
Ave just it's like give me give me like
five sentences explaining that I
guarantee you can't you can't even
explain what you mean because it doesn't
mean anything it's the same thing I
always say I go back to when men say I
feel like a woman okay really give me
five sentences about then give me five
sentences explaining what that means
that's all just tell me what it means
you can't because it doesn't mean
anything
it has no meaning
a statement devoid of meaning the phrase
my pronouns here are my pronouns these
are my pronouns that makes as much sense
as saying my verbs or my prepositions or
my adjectives these are grammatical
constructs okay you don't you don't get
to take ownership of them language isn't
your toy it isn't something that you
grab and own and say this is mine
it's rules exist and operate apart from
your desires and your narcissism you
might as well say that your verb is run
and so therefore whatever you happen to
be doing whether you're walking jogging
sitting standing lying down rolling and
around in the grass whatever you're
doing you people must describe you as
running because your verb is running now
don't you dare if you're listening to
this I don't know that's it that's a bat
'some that's a strawman of what it's not
a straw man this is exactly the same
kind of thing to say again pronoun is a
grammatical thing it's a grammatical
construct to say that it's yours here's
here's mine
it is exactly the same thing as saying
my verb my noun my adjective it makes no
sense it's not yours you can't have your
own the rules of grammar in language
okay now and whenever I talk about this
someone's quick to point out though a
grant language changes over time and it
evolves it yeah it does and I'll even
say I'll even say this language is in a
way arbitrary just in the sense that we
call a horse a horse but we don't have
to we could call it anything and and and
countries all languages all across the
globe and throughout history have had
different words to describe the large
hoofed creature that we ride right and
depending on what country you're it
they're gonna call it different things
but we can't all just come up with our
own individual words for horse you see
we have a
read upon with that's that's language
and it is objective in the sense that
it's objective that in English we call a
horse a horse now it could change over
time yes and it's different in different
countries but that is what we call it in
our language and so if you start calling
a horse cow or chair or or or cloud or
fifth or doodle if you start using that
word for horse I can say you're wrong
that that's no that's not it's not a
fifth or doodle
that's a horse okay because and here's
why because if we all just came up with
our own individual words for horses and
cows and and houses and and if we all
came up with our own individual words
for all these things we would have no
way of communicating about anything
anymore we wouldn't be able to
communicate if we all have our own word
for horse now we can't communicate about
horses anymore because I have no idea
what your word is you don't know what my
word is then what happens is language
breaks down and you are left with
nonsense
it's the same with pronouns yes we don't
have to use the words he and him in
reference to males other languages use
other words but these are our words and
if we all just get to make up our own
pronouns arbitrarily based on whatever
the hell standard then language breaks
down in our ability to communicate is
greatly hindered referring to a single
individual as they is ridiculous and
confusing and it makes no sense and I'm
convinced that that's the point the
people who make these demands are so
crushingly narcissistic so incredibly
egotistical that that they want to
control the language used about them
when they aren't even in the
and they want it to be difficult they
want you to jump through linguistic
hoops they want it to make no sense
because they enjoy the power trip of
making you dance to their tune that's
really what this is and so I don't want
to hear any any well intentioned but but
but in but wrong people say well yeah
Sam Smith is a you know it doesn't
really make any sense this they/them
thing in anybody but but you know is we
should we should go along with it
because he's confused or you know he's
not this is just an absolute egomaniac
who's trying to control is who's who
wants his own rules for language because
that's that's how interesting of a
person he is I mean listen to people
he's non-binary listen to them explain
you know how they discovered it's just
it's so it's it is it's always so
arrogant you know I look deep within
myself and I discovered that I just I
don't fit in with it see with the normal
things I just I'm saying oh shut up
already and however you feel about
yourself language does not work that way
you don't get to make up your own rules
for language that other people have to
follow when they're addressing you or
discussing you and by the way if
pronouns are meaningless basically
because they would if you're saying that
a pronoun doesn't really mean anything
so you could just change it on a whim
then why change it to begin with if
you're saying it doesn't mean anything
so if it all doesn't mean anything then
what is it to say oh I don't identify as
he or him well it doesn't that doesn't
mean anything apparently so what do you
mean you don't identify it as and you
identify as she well apparently she
doesn't mean anything either so what do
you mean you identify is that and if a
woman does not have to be she then why
is it that when a man identifies as a
woman he insists on being called she
but what's even the point of pointing ie
we could sit here all day and point out
the contradictions and the hold in the
left's gender identity everything we
could point out the contradictions all
day cuz none of it makes any sense and
they can't explain it because it's not
about making sense it's just about
control and this is the main thing I
want you to take away from this yeah we
know this is nonsense we know it's crazy
we know all that I mean if you're if
you're a rational person you know that
but the next step is for us all to
understand why they're really doing this
it's not because the Sam Smith is not
confused he doesn't think he's to people
he is not actually schizophrenic he
knows that he is a single male
individual he knows that it's about
control that's what this is about and
you know what even if you're
uncomfortable with people using the
correct pronouns when addressing you you
know what that's your problem okay
because it makes everyone else
uncomfortable when we are given these
arbitrary rules that we have to follow
and that we couldn't possibly know ahead
of time and when we are forced to engage
in nuns in nonsense speech that makes us
uncomfortable so we have a choice here
either you are uncomfortable or
everybody else's guess what in a
civilized society you at with as the
person with the unreasonable
expectations and as the person who is
uncomfortable with a reasonable thing
and the reason all thing in this case is
using grammatically correct terms you as
the person who's uncomfortable that you
just have to deal with it that's hit it
like I tell people with with pet peeves
right when when you have sought when the
and we all have this right we all we all
have things this is what a pet peeve is
a thing that a a normal thing a normal
and innocent thing that people do that
annoys the hell out of you
but if it's it because if it's a rude
thing that people do and that annoys
that's not a pet peeve that's just
that's a normal piece pet peeve is it's
a normal thing a totally normal standard
thing that people do and for whatever
reason it annoys you well in that case
that's your problem you just have to
deal with it that's your issue you can't
expect to control everybody else
everyone else doesn't have to operate
around your hang-ups and your weird
things that you got going on you just
need to control that that's your problem
for instance my pet peeve one of them I
have a many I don't like when people eat
bagels around me I don't like the sound
even what's almost chewing with their
mouths closed I don't like the sound of
people eating bagels for some reason and
maybe it's maybe I have some kind of
bagel related trauma as a child I don't
know but it's a thing and I hate it but
can I demand that every that people just
cease eating big if I walk into Panera
Bread can I say hey everybody stop put
your bagels down right now until I leave
can I do that no because that's my
problem because they're not they're not
doing anything wrong by eating bagels
I'm the one with the weird hanging up
not them and so if you have some weird
thing about how you don't like the
proper grammatical term for you that
remember first you as a male that's your
issue you just got it you got to deal
with that one all right now before we
get to emails before we get emails I
have to tell a quick story I gotta tell
today because I as it's fresh in my mind
because there's a lesson in it in in
this story a moral to it and the moral
is that
as a parent you know disaster lurks
around every corner even in mundane
situations when you least expect it so I
took my son to his first NFL game
yesterday we went to the Ravens great
game Ravens won had a blast
there was one hiccup though he in the
middle of the game he had to go to the
bathroom and unfortunately and so I took
him into the gross Stadium bathroom and
and you know if you ever if you've been
to a stadium you know that every stadium
bathroom at least every football stadium
bathroom is disgusting and it's just a
law of physics I don't know they're all
disgusting all the time
and so my son he goes into a stall and
and I'm waiting right outside the stall
and unbeknownst to me he locks the door
in the stall and I know he did that but
he did and then a line of impatient
drunks forms right waiting again and -
so they can make their own deposit and
finally he finishes up and he tries to
leave the stall but it can't figure out
he can't figure out how to unlock the
door he's he's a young kid he's six
years old he couldn't figure how to
unlock it and he was jiggling it than
any and he couldn't get it unlocked that
he's getting flustered and so I'm
talking to him through the crack in the
door I'm saying buddy buddies just
justjust turn the lock just turn it I
can't like it now just just just turn it
just just just turn the lock just just
turn it this you see this with my hand
do this do this and and then and then
and then you know and I'm turning to the
people in the line I'm saying sorry but
they're just a buddy turn the lock just
turn the lock and then I start doing the
thing where you know where you're
screaming at your kid but you're also
whispering to turn the lock people turn
to thud and anybody can't do it and so
now I'm starting to panic
my son's panicking I'm panicking now in
my head because I start to realize that
I have three options here and all of
them are horrific one I can tell him to
crawl under the door on the urine-soaked
floor and then we'll just hightail out
of the bathroom and leave this line of
drunk people to deal with the stall that
has now clocked from the inside or I can
crawl under the door
on the urine-soaked floor and unlock it
for him or option three I can leave him
in the stall go back to the game let him
figure it out let nature take its course
now so I'm going through this list in my
head and I'm getting very strong
consideration to option number three I
have to be honest with you but then I
realized that for many different legal
reasons probably number two is what its
gonna have to be and III now I'm trying
to come to grips with the fact that I am
going to have to army crawl on a stadium
bathroom floor through the collective
urine of about nine thousand drunk
people and I'm trying to come to terms
of the fact that I am going to leave
this game with hepatitis at a minimum
and and I you know I am in full freakout
mode inside my head and then just then
in that moment my son is able to free
himself for he finally figured out how
to turn it in the right direction and he
came out and so it was a you know very
close call very close call I was I
because I had this line remember and it
was you know and it was like in the in
one of the break between first and
second quarter people wanted to get back
out before the game start people were
impatient so I was I was about twenty
seconds away from crawling on that
freaking floor oh my gosh I and now as
it as a as a dyed-in-the-wool germaphobe
I am traumatized just by the thought of
what I might have had to do just the
thought of it has traumatized me all
right let's see here we'll go to emails
we'll do a couple of emails Matt wall
show at gmail.com Matt wall show at
gmail.com
from Jay
says hello there just wanted to throw an
opinion about the problem of pain yeah
I'm still getting it pretty much all my
emails about the about the problem of
suffering which we talked about last
week which which is great again I think
it's an interesting topic
alright I'll read a couple of them and
then I think we'll have to move on from
this topic eventually just wanted to
throw an opinion about the problem of
pain that you've been discussing lately
first I am fully aware that I nor anyone
else can claim to know the depth of
complexity of God and his reasons for
everything for what it's worth though
I've tended to view pain and suffering
through the idea of growth growth often
when we suffer as rat as rationing or
communes rational adults we can later
see how that event has provided
opportunity to grow and develop
spiritually emotionally and/or
physically when the innocent suffer like
your example of children suffering I
often wonder if that is for the growth
of those around them scripture has many
references to of God teaching and
affecting people not directly but
through those around him them that is
while I'd also take away the pain from
children who suffer it it may be an
effective way for growing the compassion
and empathy of others I don't think this
covers the entirety of the issue but
maybe a component worth inclusion yeah I
think it is by I think you're right in
your final sentence there that it is it
is it doesn't cover the entirety of the
issue as you admit it is a component
worth inclusion worth discussion and I
do think that pain and suffering in in
many circumstances does provide an
opportunity for growth and maturity
absolutely and that's why when I talked
about last week about how if I had a
button I could push that would take pain
and suffering away from my children I
would push it I was talking about the
severe sort of debilitating horrifying
kinds of pain and suffering but the
average everyday suffering that a kid
goes through like I got a I got to clean
my room and I don't want to which is
which is a source of immense suffering
for my kids would I take that away no I
don't because I do think that's that's
growth opportunity and and as we get
older as adults then even more severe
forms of suffering can be a for growth
no pain no gain as the cliche goes and
like many cliches there's a lot of truth
in it
as you mentioned there are I don't think
that applies to all pain and suffering I
think there is and it's important for us
to note that and that's why I keep going
back to this and I'm harping on this
fact that we have to ask Chris as human
beings as Christians and as human beings
we have to show that we understand that
we have a real understanding of of pain
and suffering and real pain and even if
we've never experienced it I think we
don't want to make the mistake of coming
across like we have learned about pain
and suffering from Christian movies and
one of my problems with Christian movies
as I've talked about the past is that
everything is way too neat and tidy and
and and there's a happy ending and
everything works out and and you know
everyone in the end is smiling and
attractive and everything and it's all
just way too perfect and even if someone
goes through something really difficult
in the end they learn from it and
they're stronger and bla bla bla
that's not the way it works in the real
world it just it's just not so even
leaving is the idea that God would give
cancer to a three year old as a learning
opportunity for his parents that I just
find I just reject that I absolutely
reject it that that's that's no I I
think again there's pain and suffering
that we are given as a learning
opportunity yes but not that no I I
don't think that when when those parents
get to the afterlife I don't think
they're gonna be told by God well I hope
you learned something from that cancer
to your child you know I know I I don't
I think that looking at it like that is
to really really severely diminish the
severity of what it means for a child to
be going through something like that and
the idea that it's just a learning
opportunity no no no and and and I
for two reasons number one that's just
completely unfair to the child that is
that that makes God come off as totally
capricious and and malevolent even that
he would give cancer to a child just to
teach a lesson to the parents I know
again I keep saying no but that's I
don't I don't accept that particular
explanation because of how it makes God
seem Millea you put guilt on the parents
like now the parents have to think 100
why must have to learn something it's my
fault that my kid has cancer because
apparently God needs to teach me
something I didn't know before so I
reject it for those reasons and also a
third reason that and this is the part
that I think a lot of the Christian
movies and everything miss that
suffering pain and suffering we say no
pain no gain but that's not always true
and I think I'll in in with with the
worst kinds of suffering people can come
out of those experiences and just be
total shells of themselves it's not true
that every time someone goes through
something difficult they come out and
they're stronger and they're better I
think there are some forms of pain and
suffering where you just you're you're
you're just ruined by it you come out
and you are ruined and you are a shell
of yourself I've seen this now I myself
am blessed enough that so far in my life
in my you know when it comes to my
closest family members and friends I
have not gone through the worst forms of
suffering yet at this point in my life
thank God but I have like many of us
I've seen it so I've been one step
removed from it which has given me a
vantage point that a lot of us have or I
know people and I've been close to
people who have gone through pretty much
the worst things you can possibly
imagine and I've seen what it's done to
them and they are not stronger because
of it I wouldn't say that to them but
but they are they are traumatized they
are ruined they are you know ruins
maybe the wrong word I don't wanna say
ruined it's just they are in some ways
weakened by it so that's that's that's
the issue and you know in and in that
that adds another layer to the problem
suffering that that you know on top of
that there are many people who have lost
their faith in God because of things
like children getting cancer whether
it's their own or just the fact that
children do so there the you know maybe
some people come out and they have a
stronger faith at the end of it but I
think a lot of people don't and the
thing is it's hard to blame them for not
having a stronger faith at the end of it
and not being stronger I could tell you
this if something like that happened to
me I talked last week about Joe Biden
and you know even though I don't like
him as a politician the things that he's
been through he lost his uh
lost his wife and child in a car
accident lost his son years later to to
cancer I mean if I lost my wife and
child in a car accident
I would not be stronger because of it I
know that right now about myself I would
be ruined I would be a shell of myself
and could you really blame me right what
does that come from because I love my
family and they because they're gone and
so I'm just uh Turley devastated by it
so what do we say about those people
what they failed the test God gave them
a test and they failed it or they can be
punished for that what happens then so I
just I don't look at it that way I guess
I guess so when we talk about the
businesses my point I keep going back to
when we talk about the problem of
suffering I don't think we can talk
about it in blanket terms there's there
are some kinds of suffering that can be
explained a certain kind of way and the
explanation you give I think that
applies to probably you know seventy
percent of the suffering that happens in
the world I don't know it's at the
totally made-up percentage but that's an
explanation that works very well for a
lot of the kinds of suffering that
people go through it works very well for
almost all of the suffering that I've
been through in my life because I
haven't I haven't been to that
really severe level yet but it does but
for that other for that next level of
suffering I think we need a different
explanation and that's where for the
third time I have to conclude that I
think we just don't have the explanation
and every explanation offered and I've
read a lot of explanations of my emails
I appreciate all the emails but I think
all the explanations I've read just they
just don't cut it they don't get to it
there's a disconnect and and so I think
we have to in the end I think we still
have to just be okay with that with the
not knowing all right we'll do one more
this is from Murray says hello supreme
bearded being dictator with the gimpy
leg well it's not so again P any more
thank you very much you've always struck
me as a good and involved dad so I have
to ask if you have any funny story slash
suggestions for me when I begin my first
first begin potty training my
two-year-old daughter I'm a little
intimidated by this monster of a project
about take on yet this thing needs to be
done I'd like to tip a tip or two your
show is great your insights bring a lot
of value well I just got there saying I
considered abandoning my child in a
restroom because I don't have to crawl
through pee so I don't know how good so
maybe I'm not the right person to be
kidding to be giving advice no I would
the only advice I would give on potty
training Marie is to work it out you
know
is something that you have to work out
yourself this is this prayer I guess is
what I would say
lots of Prayer and lots of hand
sanitizer what I'm trying to say is that
potty training in my and my experience
potty training is awful
I don't mean to scare you but it really
is discussing you think changing a poopy
diaper is bad I think that dealing with
up with a potty training child is five
times worse it's five times more gross
and especially if you're using okay
here's one solid piece of advice I'll
give you one don't use you know those
the little child potty things that they
you know which are basically just like
the chain they're basically chamber pots
they're glorified chamber pots that that
people will use and but don't use that
because I'm tell you something if you if
you're if you're training your kid on
that and he you know does his business
and that then you have to take that
disgusting pot of poop and transfer it
into the toilet and then you have to
wipe him and it's just so definitely
train them right away on the big boy
toilet and then all you have to do when
they're finished yeah mommy I'm done
come then you got to go in and you know
hold your nose flush the toilet do the
wipe flush again that's what I would say
it is definitely disgusting and horrific
and I'm sorry that you're about to
experience this but we have a we have a
we're about we're there as well our kid
our son is two and a half and so we're
gonna have to go through this again I'm
thinking maybe just keep him in diapers
until he's you know you just keep him in
diapers indefinitely until he just
figures it out on his own what I would
say is maybe that the system should be
they don't get out of diapers until
they're old enough to wipe themselves I
think that should be the system that
that's my thought but my wife never
never went for that all right we're
gonna leave it there thanks everybody
for watching Godspeed Matt Walsh show is
produced by Robert Sterling associate
producer alexia Garcia Del Rio executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Donovan
Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike quorum inna the
Matt wall show is a daily wired
production copyright daily wire 2019 hey
everybody its Andrew Clavin host of the
Andrew Clavin show you know some people
are depressed because the American
Republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moon has turned
to blood but on the Andrew Klavan show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over at the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]